هذا مجمع مستوطنات شعر هنيج الذي سنشاهده
الان وبطبيعه الحال مشاهدينا الكرام عثمان
ايضا
التكثيف الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي تركز
اليوم بالمناطق الشماليه من قطاع غزه ولكن
ايضا في المقابل العمليات الصاروخيه
الفلسطينيه للمقاومه تركزت في مناطق اسدود
وعسقلان ومحيط غلاف غزه كما نشاهد على
الشاشه لتكون دائره النار اليوم بهذا
الاتجاه عسق اسدود وعسقلان على بعد لا
يتجاوز 30 كيلومتر فقط عن شمال قطاع غزه
بطبيعه الحال وايضا في هذا العمق المناطق
الشرقيه نحن لا نتحدث عن اكثر من 15
كيلومترا كما نشاهد على الشاشه وبطبيعه
الحال كانت في دائره النار وكما لاحظنا
قبل قليل اسدود وعسقلان كما ذكر الياس
كرام قبل قليل في الناطق الشماليه من قطاع
غزه اذا اقتربنا من هذه الخريطه اكثر
واكثر فرحا نتحدث هذا هو الخط الفاصل بين
قطاع غزه والمناطق الشماليه من القطاع هنا
بيت لاهيا هذه النقطه التي كانت تتحدث
عنها هبه عكيله ونحن نتحدث من بيت لاهيا
الى زكيم حوالي اقل من سبعه كيلو مترات
وهنا يقف الياس كرام بطبيعه الحال هذه
التطورات ولكن هناك نقطه غايه في الاهميه
ومحطه التوليد الكهرباء هذه التي نشاهد
انها تمتد من البحر
بسفينه تمد هذه المحطه بالوقود وطبيعه
الحال كانت هذه المنطقه منطقه هدف
للعمليات العسكريه لصواريخ المقاومه ولكن
كثافه للقبه الحديديه في هذه في محيط هذه
المحطه المهمه التي تمد المنطقه الصناعيه
لكل منطقه عسقلان في هذا الاتجاه وبالتالي
كان هذا هدفا مهما لصواريخ المقاومه
الفلسطينيه التي انطلقت من قطاع غزه ولكن
بطبيعه الحال هذه منطقه مهمه وحساسه
بالنسبه للاسرائيليين وبالتالي القبه
الحديديه كانت على هبه الاستعداد اذا ما
انتقلنا الى المنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه ازديرود اكثر منطقه
تعرضت لل صواريخ حتى هذه اللحظه ونحن
نتحدث عن صواريخ المقاومه التي تنطلق من
هذه الاماكن وبطبيعه الحال نحل عوز التي
تستهدف بشكل كثيف من المقاومه الفلسطينيه